how's ago and rath Martin's parapa and
welcome back to Alice the madness
returns okay oh I like this new look
actually oh it felt pretty it's a pretty
she answer a mega site and all counts
assigned actually she can fly I wish I
could fly don't you ever wish you could
fly not really I think it'd be pretty
weird kind of like Chronicle I want to
fly like that that is very upsetting
journey what I'm rid of press or
whatever she's become the potato knows
yes of course at least the police I've
landed is somewhat familiar yeah I can
relate to all it yeah that's a cow I'm
too early yeah Afghan stood cat don't
try to bully me I'm very much on edge
okay perfect
when you're not on edge you're taking up
too much space I have no help at all but
you know I can be why did you strike
myself when necessary thanks very much I
was hoping to escape from all that why
see she's a casual hope a new law rings
in this Wonderland Alice it's very rough
justice all round
we're not risk here you be on your guard
of what okay so we're in the valley of
tears cool I can jump around a shed this
is way better
well hey where's the cow go cow face I
thought it's gonna be a bro but now I'm
a little disappointed oh well let's keep
going a house yes of course
Thanks no one ever complements my
jumping cow face caliphates come back
hey he's so pretty I'm gonna kiss him
I'm gonna give him a lick woo that's
that mushroom in the bubble that makes
sense I am jumping game stop telling me
to jump yeah very very pretty
all right cool it oh that's why it's
called valley of tears stop crying
crying doesn't solve anything
ah you cut whoa what I press to jump
again
twirl huh I freaking love twirl it's
like my second favorite thing I'm doing
there we go I think it how do I do that
anyway
is it from farting that would make sense
go some fart though so I guess that's
not it either it's very smooth to play
out I like it it's cool another memory
from that table again Alice I'll expire
you're two times two rekt live smile
again wow I'm sorry
jeez whoa yeah yeah yeah my memories
hello Newton Scalia Alice is merely a
stinky toast or a spongy consistency I
do i Crouch poisonous oh I gotta eat
something
all right y'all all right whoa whatever
might I don't want to eat [ __ ]
all right I'll eat you come here how do
I get in there I always tell them how to
do it Alice Alice cooperate seriously
whoo look at that [ __ ] here we go drink
me yeah we're gonna shrink I've been
down this road before good things in
small packages
sure why not lacking a bathing costume
here item that fool is in
my god I'm shrinking in this potion
should I disappear I don't know you tell
me
almost but the upside is that while
smaller you can see things that are
nearly invisible your bigger cell that's
why she fell watch it quite forest for
the trees just the other way around
short-sighted is more than a matter of
perspective okay Alice you're tripping
balls here I think there was something
weird in that juice oh I can control
shrinking are you serious
what Wow
what's up she's badly bad that's quite
love day oh I can't go up here that's
fine she's hiccuping that's awesome
Wow hell yeah all right that makes sense
look
whoa aha let's keep playing breath uh I
really know what's going on here this
game is actually I don't know it's kind
of cool Opie brothers are digging it - I
like that little little thing i'ma maybe
I should cosplay as Alice while I play
this game I'd be pretty sweet I got an
excuse to wear a dress - I'll take any
exclude uh-huh yeah that makes sense
hmm no way are we gonna are we gonna
Alice come down a let's come down yes
we're are going okay go there we go Wow
yay
what the Hayley picking up tubes because
why not the golden one
all right see if I can get all of them
Hey oh no not the snails anything about
the snails
uh-huh oh the snails gives uh-oh uh-oh
here comes the creepy part I don't like
the creepy part Brea's why is there
blood here oh okay the vorpal blade is
Swift and keen and always ready for
service
good good riding this deck huh hmm do I
get to chop come back here looking for a
fight
really that's a pity ones certainly
looking for you I don't like a kitty cat
Bram Devore ghost snicker-snack
all right it leaves them dead that's
good
the vorpal blade in clicks switch the
damage to a single target at the age
cool all right
chop chop chop oh man we're gonna chop a
lot for us
whoa whoa no no no oh I thought it's
gonna come back a lot did it did it did
it did [ __ ] off snails
that's right that's right and one was -
oh [ __ ]
never mind not that no known it's so
[ __ ] creepy what the [ __ ]
Khaled Khaled Heidi speak Japanese I
invented this hack with it that's right
I don't keep your baby oh you got
sibling that's okay I tell them to chop
the [ __ ] off whoa look at that [ __ ]
that's awesome
look at that hey how you doing all right
let's go let's go headrests because Yolo
right okey I'll thank you Oh a Sun rises
I'm sorry his purpose is simple and
immutable human purpose is fickle
because it is a slave to memory members
must be strictly managers and a drug
active ones must I come on eliminated
what is it why does he keep talking
about being unproductive I don't get
that okay well I guess we got to go over
there I'll jump hey I know that [ __ ]
please I'll tell me [ __ ] I already know
uh-huh uh-huh
damn damn girl what you gonna dope
that's what I'm talk what can be used
multiple hands while jumping whoa look
at that [ __ ]
how the hell did I do that okay well it
works what is this alcohol
what the hell did I do huh chop chop
chop
yecchh why by collecting tubes that's a
little bit I don't like that I don't
like that all right I guess we goin over
there left shift to dodge at any time
well even while jumping I did it better
don't worry there we go okay ma bottles
quite lovely quite splendid chop the top
top [ __ ] oh okay now that makes sense
hi this oh yeah Alice yes hello oh
thanks what you want to eat me watch
well you taught me manners and I've lost
my taste for mad women strictly a poor
thigh and diet for me everything's
better with bacon don't you agree of
course you do
she does have a point I heard a few
behind the house go fetch them for me
but take care for the pests that block
your way pepper them up if they do they
need spice and you're just the did a
girl to season them for me once find
that grinder serviceable why not season
your own pig parts yeah why not I have
priorities my alabaster skin needs
protection from the disgusting creatures
running amok commits the environs but
upon its peckish look all you have to do
is listen for the oink then shoot the
snout you may like the results I
certainly will I like she's little like
casual about everything like however the
normal pepper Greiner best spice up your
foes prepares savory snouts all right
what job Pat you're hot you're hot hello
whatever hello
know what I bought whoa
all right Bolton flies almost anything
but the Bolton flies
hasta la vista balls and flatten those
hills yeah bring it on Boulder flutters
bring it is that all you got both the
flutters or I'll show you I'll show you
how it's done both the plateaus you try
to sneak up behind me huh always taking
the bus well shut it works
ah I'm immediate I mean small okay sure
chop chop chop
oh snap it is snow on the shoe what you
gonna do that's right that's right I may
be a woman but I have kids that make
okay whatever come in [ __ ] off
that's right tab switch enemies no what
the [ __ ] was that Alice what are you
doin ocean oh no don't worry about don't
worry about don't worry about don't
worry about don't worry about don't
worry about don't worry about okay
where's my sneaker OOP I'm salt shakers
how do I equip that [ __ ] fabric oh
there we go
hasta la vista salty shankara come on
aah
abaca oh my god that's why I'm taking me
anyone else
ah anyone else want some salt and pepper
no thanks
hi thanks up [ __ ] a big guy
that's what I was talking about before
you hear me well yeah ah [ __ ] how dare
you shut up
Alice there we go oh they go quite
splendid what anyone else where are they
hell yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] on oh [ __ ] oh no those [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off [ __ ] the [ __ ] off oh oh oh ah
[ __ ]
alright yep ah it will reveal pass and
collectable thanks that's nice that
makes sense
alright sniff test [ __ ]
there we go a flying Mills yeah that
make sense
all right so he flew in there flew in
there I am a tiny person and I can
teleport into trees apparently come on
Alice I can teleport any way I want um
but not inside a tree Keith hey guy
what's up you so much for the snout
you're welcome go away
hey you could at least thank me Oh ed
she did she did thank me didn't she
break the Duchess Bachelor to receive a
new one how about I break your boobs huh
no well screw you I'll break the basket
whoa whoa all right it's been good
um you're welcome you may want to tell
now in the Botox a little bit especially
in the lips just say hi I'm not trying
to be a fencer but you know smarter
whatever
I love how's your hiccups when she go
somewhere all right
what else's that's another one of us
hello sir let me shoot you sniff my [ __ ]
and by Chet I mean my pepper all right
what else is gonna what is going to show
me oh my god
oh that dramatic sound effect I get the
feeling I should not have done that but
hey okay okay
everything is fine don't even worry
about it part 2 cha cha cha cha cha
Tom just attach the top to top these
hubs of cha for my truck I'll chop you
and I'll chop you anyone else with a
chop
hasta la vista [ __ ] oh that's
right oh that's right top to chop da
Dada I give up top to top to top to top
da da da that's right [ __ ]
anyone else anyone else add it what else
there think so